les biens ces trois compagnies
d'eure-et-loir invite les visiteurs à
une balade spectacle dans le jardin de
ce café brocante bouddhiste complotistes
dentiste communiste garagiste centriste
botaniste futuriste c'est l'une des
animations organisées ce week end à
l'initiative des artistes pour soutenir
ce café associatif nous en tant que
petite compagnie
ces lieux là et sont vitaux pour nous
ils sont vraiment très importants que
c'est des endroits où on peut jouer et
on peut montrer notre travail est en
fait ben là il ya eu les événements du
coc vide et plein de choses et ce lieu
ils étaient un petit peu en danger et
donc du coup on voulait vraiment le
soutenir pour qu'ils continuent à
exister et qui se passe des choses ici
il faut dire que le café la récré tenu
par une poignée de bénévoles se trouve à
chapelle royale une commune d'à peine
300 habitants au sud de l'eure et loir
c'est difficile de faire vivre a lieu
comme ça c'est même avec les subventions
du département même avec des dons d'arte
d'adhérents c'est compliqué
financièrement il fallait remettre aussi
dans dans l'esprit des gens le fait que
la récré site est là et que l'on
n'existait que c'était sympa d'y venir
donc c'était le deuxième objectif je
crois qu'il est aussi assez importants
offerts entre les repas les comptes et
les spectacles l'objectif semble atteint
c'est génial qu'il ya un mélange de
cultures je trouve ça marche très bien
quoi ré ce qu'ils font à chapelle royale
quand même type est comme ça après le
confinement
le café aura retrouvé ce week end les
rires des enfants comme à son origine
il abritait une école de filles en tout
ils sont une trentaine d'artistes locaux
à s'être investis pour que vive la récré